a pesar del todo la artillería misiles
que se escuchan sobre Bag good en este
momento quienes están aquí dicen que hoy
está bastante más tranquilo que días
anteriores porque la lucha se ha
desplazado a esa población de Soledad a
siete kilómetros de aquí hacia nuestras
espaldas sin embargo también soldados de
las fuerzas ucranianas que están
alrededor dicen que dentro de esa ciudad
la lucha básicamente es mínima solamente
hay algunos hombres la mayor parte de la
lucha están las afueras de Soledad
muchas de las brigadas que estaban allí
o la mayoría se han retirado por una
decisión militar una misión que ellos
han llamado estratégica y dicen quienes
estaban A los alrededores que ir a
soledad es solamente de una vía es
imposible básicamente en este momento
regresar Pero ellos dicen que eso
también tiene unos significados
estratégico las fuerzas rusas han
perdido muchísimos en esa lucha están
según ellos disminuidos a pesar de que
han traído Más Fuerzas a esta región del
Tomás y eso esa calma por ejemplo se
siente hoy aquí en backmud que ha sido
atacada menos que en días anteriores
pero hablando con la población que ha
decidido quedarse y que vive de ayuda
humanitaria nos dicen que aquí ha sido
tan dura la lucha en estos últimos meses
que cualquier cosa que venga en el
futuro no puede ser peor la realmente la
gente está afectada pero a quienes le
preguntamos Por qué se quedan dicen que
porque no tienen otro lugar a donde ir
hoy también se ha visto la división que
hay dentro de las fuerzas rusas el
Ministerio de defensa y los militares
clamaban la victoria de soledad pero
eran las fuerzas Wagner quienes dicen
que ellos libraron esa batalla y se
veían divisiones y han sido también
ellos quienes han Librado la mayor parte
de esa lucha por bacmut que a pesar de
todas estas semanas y meses tratando de
tomarla a pesar la destrucción que hay
en esta ciudad como hemos podido ver no
han podido hacerlo